all right over the past 25 years scream
fans all over the world have had some
incredible viewing parties so i asked my
culinary partner in crime chef pilar
valdez to come up with some
really fun
spooky treats that everybody can make
for their viewing party especially now
that you all have these awesome
collectors items of these 4k dvds of the
original movie so if you're at home and
you're gonna have a screen viewing party
pallar
what you got all right so first up it
wouldn't be a scream viewing party
without some jiffy pop oh right now well
some jiffy pop going over here and i
hope i don't burn
it's starting to get starting to pop so
i'm gonna just like park it and move it
back oh that's so sad while that's
popping on the side-ish
we're going to do a little bit of a
beverage
i've got a beet and ginger beer ooh
uh it's a mocktail so it's completely
non-alcoholic and then we have little
ghost face cups over here which is just
basically a black cup and then you can
take a little bit of a white marker or
white out
and draw your favorite ghost face over
there
that is a very unique pilar
it does taste like a cocktail it's very
fancy very earthy
so it is beet juice but then we use a
little ginger beer which is
non-alcoholic
and then a little lemon and honey and
you top it off with tonic water and it
feels it has that vibe of a cocktail i
would say
and this tastes like a really great
cocktail yup it's all really a really
good base shall we move on yeah all
right i love this
in honor of your guts on the show we
made you mean because i end up hanging
from a tree with unfortunately with her
guts spilling out so this is a cross
between a pull apart bread a sharon tara
bread and a pizza and we basically
stuffed it with parmesan and mozzarella
and pepperoni oh my god all of that's in
there all that's in there there's a
knife but i feel like we can also just
like tear at it and then we serve it
with a little bit of a like a tomato
sauce on the side that you can sort of
dip and swipe as you go i think i pulled
the large intestine i i'm going for the
small intestine over here so i recipe
tested this
oh my god
i have to say
this is amazing
it's kind of like a mouthful but it
doesn't taste like a pizza it tastes
like
it's so unique
it's super satisfying real crowd pleaser
and you can really shape it into
anything but i think the guts is really
a nice touch i love that and then you've
got the bloody sauce i'm so in carry on
all right moving on we've got a little
bit of a sweet
we're gonna go that way
and we have these beautiful
vanilla
lemon cupcakes with a little bit of a
candy knife i think some of them have
access and some of them have knives
and then drew i'm gonna have you
cut into it actually you i love
it
i like peter wielding that knife
and we have a little bit of a surprise
in the middle
so if you cut all the way down it's
stuffed with a little cherry pie filling
so it's an uzi
bloody cupcake um this is delicious i'm
really into the bloody inside um it's
cherry pie filling cherry pie mm-hmm oh
my god it's so
it's like a play on a vanilla cherry
soda basically i absolutely love it to
finish off you ready drew yes are you
sure
all right
the last thing
all right so we took some popcorn
and here we have a little bit of a
bloody
butter
for our popcorn wait a minute how do you
make bloody butter it's melted butter a
little cayenne a little red coloring and
a little salt
and if i had a bowl i would mix that for
you properly but you're going to paste
pour it over
et voila that's beautiful
[Applause]
flour oh well i like it with a little
bit of the cayenne yeah it has a little
bit of heat a little tiny bit of heat on
there and like at the very end at the
end yeah very slowly
like
like this like that one very subtle over
here i'm so grateful to all the ghosts
face in our audience and everyone here
for being scream fans and supporting
this endeavor and the release of this
new film that's going to make people so
happy and come together and like
celebrate life
in the you know in a horror movie kind
of way
challenges
and
for all of those movies that you can
binge in anticipation of the release
go to our website at
thedrewbrymerchow.com to get all of
pilar's crazy amazing recipes
[Music]
you